um arvind is assistant professor of
management science and engineering at
Stanford University he is a member of
the center of work technology and
organization the Stanford technology
Ventures program and a faculty affiliate
of the institute for human-centered
artificial intelligence
um his current research focuses on human
AI augmentation in the workplace and its
organizational impact Arvin is presently
working on a new course for our digital
transformation program and it will be
released later on this year welcome
arvind let's let's get right going with
this little hiccup to begin with our
first question in this fireside chat is
um to start
um what uh could you talk about what are
the emerging capabilities and challenges
or risks of using generative AI in a
workplace context
thank you thanks thanks Anita uh super
excited to be here uh so there are a lot
of emerging capabilities as we are
finding out every day like people are
discovering new use cases of generative
AI uh but if we sort of try to
understand the technology a bit more
what is generative AI it's essentially
gen AI is enabled by large language
models or foundational models as they're
called trained on a broad set of like
structured and unstructured data and
essentially data that we find on the
internet a lot of uh these llms are
trained at least the ones we have uh
they could also be trained specifically
to a vertical say there's one now for
finance there's going to be another for
the medical Indus medical profession so
that's going to also change the change
how people are going to use these
Technologies but looking across we could
think of two broad used cases right or
two categories if you will one is around
generating content the another is around
extracting summarizing or predicting
information right so these are two broad
categories at least as of now uh on the
use of generative AI the capabilities
with respect to generating content it is
about any anything from uh generating a
personalized image or video or
converting like a text to a video
generating music so there are a lot of
applications with respect to generating
content and this was the part that
people were quite surprised by earlier
on uh you know if you ask someone about
Ai and both potential capabilities are
and where it would affect creative
industries were not the first that
people it was not the first that came to
people's mind right people thought okay
maybe these could be used in automating
routine tasks and you know more lower
level tasks that does not involve a lot
of like you know discretion and
creativity but uh donating content is
one of the biggest like capabilities of
generative AI the second uh use case
which is about uh extracting summarizing
content essentially so if you have like
a you know quarterly report or any form
of um uh you have like a recording of uh
of a meeting it's quite good at
summarizing that text right and uh all
the way from uh reasoning about text
images to high you know having some form
of chat Bots where you train on all the
customer issues your company your
product uh at face in the past and you
could generate these automatic chat Bots
to essentially accelerate the customer
service process right so these are the
two broad generating content extracting
summarizing predicting information or
the two broad use cases and within that
we seeing industry specific how these
Technologies are being used adapted so
the legal industry for instance is one
that is getting impacted a lot because
that is like dependent it's a very text
Heavy industry and industries
organizations that rely our functions
that rely a lot on texts and images and
language more broadly those are the
functions at least as of now uh are like
impacted the most right legal industry
the paralegals are using general a a lot
to you know discover like legal
precedence or to generate contracts ndas
and stuff like that in advertisement
agencies and more creative Industries
graphic designers are already using
these Technologies copywriters to
generate a lot of options slogans for
their clients so these are the very high
level these are some of the emerging
capabilities of of AI and as we use it I
think the important point model I want
to sort of emphasize is these use cases
nobody could
find them out ahead of time it is it is
discovered in use as you do the work as
you augment your work with these
Technologies such as GPT and Dali and
part and others uh you would discover
new ones all right so so those are the
capabilities people are also using
organizations who are using them to uh
what they call as associate listening
which is basically like an employer
survey employment survey across the
company before these would be like
multiple choice questions and there will
not be enough like free form questions
where people can say okay what are some
of the issues in the company or what do
they want because it's very hard to
analyze them imagine if it is like a you
know a 5000 member company now it is
quite easy to do that to summarize find
patterns in text to categorize the text
and so forth so those are the capable
abilities with respect to the risks
already people have been talking about
it the biggest risk is uh What uh
Scholars call as the hallucination
problem right so essentially it is these
Technologies generate newer content with
a lot of confidence or like sounding
very confidently but it is just made up
content right so for instance if I went
and asked the uh one of these gen AI uh
chat Bots to generate a biography of of
me or anyone as any of my colleagues it
gets it completely wrong from even the
basic facts right so that's the problem
the hallucination problem but if you use
it for more serious tasks say research
tasks uh it gets like you know uh it's
sometimes like invents content with like
with a very in a confident voice so
there is always some element of humans
involved the humans need to be there to
cross-check these Technologies so that's
the first Blood risk the second is
related to copyright and IP especially
if you're a large company or even a
freelancer trying to you know generate
content sometimes there is a risk of
copyright an IP especially on what these
llms are trained on right so there's
already been an issue and some companies
have tried against using uh against
using these Technologies to generate new
images right for legal reasons the third
uh the third risk was related to privacy
especially if you try to generate code
uh so there are there are companies
again that have like cut off access to
these Channel GPT and other chat bots in
part for review privacy consists they
don't want to expose their own code or
use like you know unverified code
generated by these Technologies and the
final risk is related to numerical
reasoning uh so as I mentioned these
Technologies are trained uh like large
language based content so it's very good
at like language related tasks image
related tasks but with respect to
numerical reasoning uh even so simple
sort of arithmetic to all the way to you
know more advanced like you know
internship programming or Advanced
numerical reasoning it's still not there
it's still a work in progress or
numerical reasoning I would be like you
know careful or have some human in the
loop to verify the results that the
technology is producing it is very good
at consolidating data sets and you know
merging datasets finding patterns but
numerical reasoning it is still not
there so I would caution there's some
kind of a risk associated with that so
these are the four risks I could think
about hallucination copyright privacy
numerical respect
excellent uh that was very helpful
um and uh thank you for bringing it all
together we see a lot in uh news and and
articles on the topic and it's great
that you know you brought it all
together for everybody
um next question
um how do we cut through the current
hype right all this news and information
that's coming out all of what what's the
real thing that's going to happen what
do you think might happen so current
hype around AI Chachi BT and how do we
appreciate the potential we're getting
questions about this how do we
appreciate the potential of generative
AI for the future of work
yeah great great question uh so
essentially as I mentioned uh the use
cases are discovered people are doing
their work it's not that they could sit
and think through I mean some of it they
might uh but a lot of the tasks that
people do you know the potentially
discovered as people are like using
these Technologies so I'd give an
example on what you know what
facilitates this use this creative use
of generative AI as opposed to what
hinders that and this is actually based
on some research that we are currently
doing in multiple companies uh so this
isn't a use of generative AI in a
corporate law firm so this is used to
corporate law firms as you know generate
a lot of like you know contracts and
ndas and documents it's very document
every industry so the paralegals like
are the ones who are responsible for
generating contracts and service level
agreements and ndas for the client which
takes like a substantial amount of time
because each client is like a specific
unique capabilities so this organization
adopted a tool this is even before chat
GPT there were other vertical specific
uh generative AI Technologies this is
specific to the legal industry uh so
they use this as a test case to find out
okay what would be you know what are the
new application areas use cases for this
technology and they found the first use
case was around very simple generating
non-disclosure agreements for clients
who are putting together contracts like
by merging multiple different contracts
in the past uh so that was the first use
case and this Law Firm two different
subdivisions the same Law Firm adopted
the technology very similar many
structural Dimensions uh one of the
subdivisions the paralegals were using
this technology a lot more they were
discovering new use cases they were for
example discovering new use cases around
or I could use this technology energy
not just to construct contracts and ndas
but also to you know find like legal
precedent or do some like background
legal research because all of that is
textual data that the model could be
trained on the other division people
where the paralegals were resisting
using the technology right they don't
want to be they don't want to use it or
they were finding some kind of issues
with it right so we got very curious on
why is this the case is the same company
same technology the two subdivisions are
also more or less the same similar type
of paralegals too and that's where we
found the important role that managers
played the managers and these two
subdivisions the subdivision where there
was a lot more adoption and use the
paralegals were discovering new use
cases that they haven't thought of
before or the organization hasn't
thought of or even the vendor technology
vendor hasn't thought of in that
subdivision the managers were signaling
possibility of re-skilling their job to
essentially rediscovering what a
paralegal is today right it's less about
like you know routine word less about
contracts due diligence stuff like that
uh the signaling was try to discover new
use cases that makes your job easier or
at least the tasks that you hate to do
or they start or could you do something
could you augment that with these
Technologies uh and there was less
emphasis on consolidation are we going
to sort of you know make are we going to
replace some of you so that rhetoric was
not there in that first subdivision
where we saw a lot of use and a lot of
experimentation in the division where
there was less adoption and use the the
signal that managers sent to us let's
surround reskilling or upskilling right
they were not saying okay we would use
this technology as an opportunity for
you to ReDiscover your job or your role
so there the people got like the it sort
of invoked the threat frame to those
paralegals right they were not willing
to experiment with the technology and
the process they were not able to
discover new use cases or even if they
did discover an experiment they were not
willing to share it widely with their
other colleagues other paralegals or
their managers right so I think the
broader Point here is
the managers are going to play a much
more important role than we think in
appreciating the potential of
regenerative AI because these gets
discovered in news right nobody could
plan ahead of time but having said that
the one thing I would uh sort of suggest
is if you are an employee or a worker
it's it's important to think about do
some form of a task inventory right what
are the tasks that you do there might be
a job description about you that says
these are the tasks you do but then
there might be a lot more stuff that you
do beyond that right doing that like
essentially then trying to figure out
what are the tasks that could be
augmented by these Technologies and what
are the tasks that you want to do in the
future that you're not doing something
that you're passionate about for example
in the paralegals case they wanted to be
involved more in the client uh facing
business too they want to get involved
in the legal strategy meetings and a lot
more like upskill tasks uh likewise what
are the tasks that are that you're not
currently doing you want to do that uh
you so that sort of you could use a
generative AI to enable that so that's
another way to think about it doing a
task inventory and thinking about the
potential of how would you augment your
current skills with the technology right
so these are the two things I would say
in order to appreciate the potential you
have to use it and the managers need to
sort of be supportive of the use and
experimentation
Sunita
great
um you know I'm looking at the questions
that are coming in and you're already
answering a number of them
um and uh it's great to see everybody
thinking a little bit of step ahead of
what arvin's talking about and then you
know you're hopefully your answers are
your questions are getting answered
um one more question let's see if we
could squeeze in one more question yeah
um let's see here
um what are some of the best practices
of human a eye augmentation
that have worked so far
yeah very positive positive constructive
impact
great uh so
I would say the biggest resistance of
what I call as The Last Mile problem of
AI right the people who are needs to use
this technology they are like not
trusting it enough or they don't want
experiment or they experience this
threat frame that this technology is
going to replace me or I'm going to make
my job lot less important so that is a
prominent reason why or maybe the
technology is not there yet initially it
might get better but it will only get
better and people use it give their
feedback right so these are the barriers
so the best practice that I've seen work
uh especially to drive more use
experimentation of AI is to start if
you're a manager or organization to
start start with the task that people
hate to do right so that's the task that
you could use these Technologies ask
them to sort of find ways to augment
automate that and there people would be
pretty receptive to that right because
that's a task that they already hate to
do for the paralegals case again it's
not that it's not a lot of fun
generating contracts in ndas like given
the given the skills of the paralegals
so that's one best practice start with
the task that's like people hate to do
the second is uh related to what I
mentioned uh uh trying to come up with
the task inventory uh of like what kind
of stuff people do and Mappo the
dependencies between the tasks
especially in an organizational context
it is not one individual doing all the
stuff without any dependencies on others
there's a lot of coordination back and
forth so uh you might be okay with
experimenting using these Technologies
but your colleague might not if your
Downstream colleague might not right so
trying to map out those dependencies
earlier on uh that is also helpful so I
I call this a thought the task
augmentation problem essentially within
a job there are multiple tasks only some
of them could be automated or augmented
using AI not all so trying to figure out
what they are and map all the
dependencies and the last one is around
the the role of managers the best
practice uh I mean the managers started
to Signal consolidation or replacement
if that is where The Narrative that
they're trying to set uh that then
definitely the the use of AI would
reduce the diffusion adoption of AI by
the people who are supposed to you know
experiment with these technologies that
would reduce but if they signal
something I mean they cannot promise
that there'll be no consolidation or no
job replacement but at least if they
signal that there are opportunities to
rethink re-imagine your job uh what you
ideally want to do and potential for
reskilling and upskilling your job that
drives people to experiment a lot more
share their insights a lot of these
insights are shared collectively shared
and that's how uh the capabilities of
the Technologies too are discovered and
protectors so I think these are the
three best practices I would say
great thank you
um let's go ahead and take one question
from the audience
um
if you
um were a young Professor you are a
young Professor
for the young Professionals in our
audience
um what would you recommend they they
study now with this generative Ai and
you know uh and then and then the other
question that it has popped up a couple
times is um how is this being used in
education how is it going to change
education
um so how do you prepare the new
Professionals of the future and then how
is how are you teaching maybe
differently yeah so I'd start with the
first one on what you should focus on
and I cannot give a like a blanket
answer depends on your your area what
your sort of current uh interests are
and so forth but essentially I would uh
and Chris whatever your job is trying to
see how you could augment these
Technologies right uh generate away as a
part of your workflow so that's the one
thing I would suggest and there are like
courses around that on how do you use
generative AI as a part of your work so
that's something maybe like a baseline
understanding of what these Technologies
are capable of or not capable of could
also be helpful to figure out okay where
you could best use this technology and
where this is not a really good fit at
least at this point in time so that's
all that I could I could say as of now
the question on education and we are
trying to experiment a lot at Stanford
and breathing you know how we teach our
courses but also what kind of like
assignments that we should give to
students should we sort of cut off like
access to chat GPD or and uh or are
there other ways to rethink uh how we
sort of test students this this because
my perspective and I use this in my
courses is to actually allow students to
use these Technologies you know if they
want to write an essay or any form of
assignment a presentation for that
matter they are allowed to use it but
then they also had to be very reflective
of the process and training them to
write good prompts uh being like
teaching a course on that like how do
you write good prompts at least a few
sessions on on that so that's going to
be an important skill uh and then owning
the content like how do you do cross
verification especially given the
hallucination problem it talked about
right so how do you do that that's
another or do you essentially fact check
and make sure that whatever you're
producing is like solid it's robust
content uh the third is how do you
integrate all of these to your own sort
of workflow right the students are going
to go into like you know workplace uh so
I'm trying to structure the assignments
in the manner that they could use chat
GPT and there will be something thing
some kind of task where you would not be
able to use the questions are framed in
a manner that it involves a lot more
research and going to the library or
like just critical thinking so how do
you integrate this too so those are the
things that I try to teach and they need
to also write a reflect to like one page
like you know Reflections on their use
of this technology what they learned
what word what and what how did they
experiment right so I think that's what
I would suggest to for even for
employees doing the work cutting off
access is not probably a great idea of
course there are given the privacy and
other risk organizations might take a
different route but allowing people to
experiment is the best possible group
great thanks it's as somebody
um made a comment and uh rightfully so
not just young professionals all
professionals
um those of us have been around for some
time
um need to learn the new technology and
how we can use it to better the
experience in an environments and and
for the future and do it in a way that's
safe and and equitable
yeah absolutely yeah yeah okay can I
have like one quick Point absolutely
given this is we've given this a chatbot
I think one of the issues that I'm
seeing my students but also others is uh
given the how we are used to doing
search like using search engines and
giving like Search keywords people are
using a very similar approach when they
use these chatbots chat GPT bot or any
of these that it's not a search engine
like if you the if you write a prompt as
a search keyword it is not super
effective right so that's why I
emphasize the importance of prompt
engineering how do you write a good prom
and therefore to understand the
technology more would help you to you
know write better prompts too so a move
from like a Search keywords and search
queries to prompts is going to be an
important skill for all all people to
learn irrespective of like you know
angled
excellent advice thank you
the webinar and
I went at the start of it and hung in
there as we got going and
um I do want to remind everybody that
Arvin is in the process of developing a
new course for the digital
transformation program it should be out
this fall
um that's what we're targeting and
um
like Ai and how to write prompts and
stuff like that
awesome
time if you want to um
command we would recommend get started
on your digital transformation
certificate
um now there are four core courses that
we recommend everybody take
um as you start the program and then by
the time arvin's course goes live you'll
be ready to go if you have further
questions about the program or The
Learning Journey with the digital
transformation program please feel free
to reach out to us via email or chat and
with that I want to thank everybody for
joining us today Arvin thank you
for joining us today and uh sharing what
you're seeing not not only in Academia
but also the experience that you're
doing
um uh with the work that you're doing in
Industry so thank you everybody and we
wish you all a great day